so today when a user goes in and they
actually download the brd wallet like
what is the functionality that's in
there and what can they what they do
yep absolutely that's exactly the right
way to think about it like what are the
practical use cases so
it's always been known for simplicity um
and security
and you know it's an implementation of
bitcoin in a more pure sense so it comes
with all the other benefits of bitcoin
it's really an on-ramp it's the easiest
way to get started so when you launch
the app
it's what i really the reason why we
grew really fast
um and the reason why i think by guys
like roger ver
who invested in blockchain.info but
probably
is the individual responsible for the
single
most installs of brd on
on customer devices the reason is
because uh there's no onboarding
right it's not like going to a bank or
you know
an exchange and creating an account you
literally download the app you hit new
wallet boom you can start sending and
receiving crypto
right so i could just send you scan your
qr code send you some bitcoin right now
that's a really great way when you meet
someone in a restaurant or a family
member at dinner or in a bar and you
they say where do you work i work in
crypto i've heard about that what is
that
you download you know an exchange app
the guy's there for 30 minutes taking
selfies
trying to establish them again that's
not a great crypto experience
right that's not what bitcoin's supposed
to be that's a bank account right
you download the vrd app boom within
five seconds you know i can send you
some bitcoin oh that's how it works
that's pretty cool right so the
onboarding gets them in it makes it easy
and ultimately what you can do is you
can um buy
and sell crypto and you can trade and
it's really targeted
more at the like i said robin hood sort
of audience casual investor
not the high frequency you know traders
doing day trading who are sitting on
exchanges constantly
right that's the trade-off that you get
is we focus on the ux
uh we want to help you know sort of the
uh the average individual
global citizen get on to the crypto
bandwagon
and um you know that's the sort of the
the the rule we play it's kind of like
your robin hood customer
versus like your charles schwab customer
for example
for sure and then um you guys also have
come out with
uh block set by brd uh which is even an
advertiser here on
on the podcast and uh maybe talk a
little bit about kind of what the uh
idea or the genesis was for uh for that
body of work and then kind of what you
guys have built so far
okay sure thanks bob so yeah we worked
really hard to build
a brand around vrd and i think a big
reason
that the crypto folks early on uh
really helped accelerate the growth of
the company and the app is because
they trusted us it's open source right
so there's no funny business with you
know all your money's going to disappear
someday and we've never had any money
hacked from from any brd app actually
right because it's decentralized there's
like no honeypot right
and so we took that brand that trust and
that sort of
you know technology right and it
actually it happened as a result
uh to be honest with you of our
relationship with sbi
so remember i said that i started to
really get into the japanese sort of
relationships and business
well when we created brd
i came back to japan and we actually
raised a lot of money from here
and then later in the company's
evolution svi contacted us and they said
hey we'd really like to include the brd
consumer app
in our new crypto banking flow by the
way we'd like to invest some money in
your company
and at the time we weren't even raising
money we told them i said we weren't so
interested but
uh eventually um we ended up you know
taking the strategic investment from
them
and as part of that investment we sat
down with their technology teams they've
got some really smart people pumped here
in tokyo
and and what they said was well okay now
we understand how your architecture
works
you ought to take the back end of your
consumer app
okay which is you know sort of like the
server side right
talks to all these from blockchains and
maybe we could use that too
and so our cto and i and the management
team sat down and we thought you know
what there's a really big opportunity
here so we took
the back end of the consumer app talks
to all the different blockchains
we productized it we turned that into
block set a set of building blocks to
basically help companies
build software for blockchain access
quicker right and at lower cost and
don't have to run nodes or
infrastructure costs
and i think really importantly it's out
there in production with four million
customers for the vrdf so you can trust
it
right plus the core of its open source
as well so we productized it
with help from svi svi became our first
customer block set
they launched in production with it a
few weeks ago actually for their crypto
banking
platform and uh now it's a product that
we're selling
in our enterprise sort of um division of
the company
and we're having great success just in
the last few months since it launched
um and you know we appreciate all the
folks out there helping us with that
getting the word out like you are and um
we've got major accounting firms now
signed we're working with
um big cross-border payment companies i
can't really say the names but they're
the big companies that you would know
and you know it's just about them
looking at this it's like the early days
of say like cloud um you know hosting
like aws and azure got started and
initially it's like well we do all that
in-house and they're like well wait a
minute builders is why it's a lot
cheaper to do it that way i can trust
that one a lot more
and i can actually grow my business
faster but i need a solution that is
really scalable
not just this little you know sort of
api to access a few blockchains that
works once in a while i need something
that can scale to the size of you know
a fortune 100 companies needs that's
what blocks it is
that's what we built and so it's it's
like a infrastructure
you know apis to access the blockchains
infrastructure for like next generation
banking
got it and so is the whole idea there
that um similar to how aws provides
really that infrastructure layer people
can tap
into it and kind of do all these things
cheaper faster
more scalably you guys are doing that
and not only helping them build their
products but also then giving them
access to the various blockchains as
well
right that's right so it's it's not so
aws is more like you know hosting
compute resources
right and so when you're when you want
to build blockchain apps
right certainly one of the big issues is
like running your own
say bitcoin node or riffle node or
theory node actually that costs a lot of
money
but just running nodes that's just one
piece of of value that we add
right the real value i think is we have
one api okay that means there's one set
of functions to call by the developed by
an engineer
to access any blockchain that actually
is pretty powerful because today
if i'm sitting at a bank and i want to
offer say
crypto bank accounts to my customers
i've got to write
code to talk to bitcoin bitcoin cash
ethereum you know all these
other blockchains then there's forks and
there's all these changes
and there's bugs and man it's a lot of
work not to mention
that i got to have a legion of of
engineers who understand the nuances of
each blockchain
what blockset does is it puts a layer on
top of
all those individual blockchains whether
they're private or public
and it basically um mine it takes all
the data from them
has this sort of metadata layer because
we can analyze the blockchain data as
well and then there's one api on the top
so your engineers only have to code to
one spec and as we add more blockchains
in
in the block set sort of you know sas
environment
then those blockchains just immediately
become available
you know to to the to our customer who's
building blockchain software with
blockset
and they don't have to do any real
incremental coding or anything right
plus we handle all the infrastructure
issues running the servers to the forks
to the maintenance
you know and all those things as well
and then we've got partners that
that do things like aml and transaction
checking right and
custody as well so you could build you
know custodial banking apps with with
whatsapp like sbi did right and
you could just you know myriad sort of
applications you want to add virtual
cryptocurrency or virtual currency to a
video game you know you could you could
do it with lockset as well
so kind of anything and that's